the first episode from season 2 of
Batman the telltale series is out and
we've got some gameplay over the first
15 minutes now if you'd like to see
other videos of the game including the
full review and even an interview with a
voice of the Joker subscribe to the
GameSpot YouTube channel for more one
fateful night my parents gave their
lives for me they became my heroes their
legacy untouchable until I learned the
truth my father Thomas Wayne was a
criminal he willed over Gotham from the
shadows and everything I thought I knew
about myself changed forever the
children of Arkham exposed the truth
about my father to Gotham their attack
turned friends and enemies and threw the
city into chaos I was committed to
Arkham Asylum where I escaped with the
help of a mental patient named John Doe
after a bloody battle I put it into it
all in the catacombs beneath the city
the penguin two-face at lady Arkham were
the first real challenge I faced as the
Batman but they would not be the last
Spring has arrived in Gotham and with it
comes City Hall's quarterly crime report
crime is way down since the fall of the
children of Arkham marking another
triumph for newly minted Police
Commissioner James Gordon in a statement
this morning Gordon credited his success
to the public partnership between the
police and the Batman he praised the
mysterious vigilante for his sacrifice
describing him as essential to the
security of the city things are looking
up citizens after the long dark winter
comes the law now if only the Knights
could win again everyone would be happy
lucky 13 there it is pro-v poori
import-export bagnat one time pipe
ex-ceo international arms dealer the
world sees Mori is a legitimate
businessman a philanthropist who gives
to charity not a criminal getting rich
off the suffering of innocence a
masterful performance I wonder if a man
hides in plain sight for that long as
you forget who he really is what do you
think master Bruce must be hard to stay
true to yourself we all wear masks in
public every day is a thousand little
performances perhaps but some are more
encompassing than others masks are hard
to maintain if there are cracks in
Morrie's we'll find them
the GCPD already bugged his penthouse
and found nothing meaning that if he's
doing arms deals in Gotham they happen
on the casino floor I need to find a way
to hear what Mori is saying
standing by him for support look for
something with a microphone the
Batcomputer can intercept his
communication Oh
I'm hacking in a Maurice phone
encrypting your signal last thing we
want is for him to know you're here
we're in you should be able to pick up
audio from Lori's phone
is everyone enjoying themselves don't
worry I won't tell anyone with a bear
he's on a roll it's only a matter of
time before he gets too chatty
try to blend in
so I've been sitting over there
wondering what's Bruce Wayne doing in a
place like this I figured you went to
fancy a casinos don't tell anyone but
I'm here undercover don't worry I can
keep a secret you what didn't the hell
are you doing here stop me if you've
heard this one before I begin and have
no end and I end all that begins Who am
I I don't give a damn I told you ten
times our arrangement is over death
Maury I am death
something's happening and it doesn't
look like a deal
the man in the hood I remember hid from
your father's time I think that's
Riddler
is something wrong you seem distracted
Bruce how about we go back to my place
oh I'll call my driver meet me outside
well since you put it like that I never
do this
you know you no me neither no one
threatens me in my own casino security
sir it's time to leave for you an easy
one
what question can you never not say yes
till I don't give a crap let's go the
correct answer is are you dead
[Music]
let's get started
[Music]
get out of there get your suit
[Music]
now let Gordon know what's happening
right away
[Music]
[Music]
Commissioner Gordon on the line
scrambling audio and now Gordon Batman
what's the status
[Music]
multiple gunmen hostages at the casino a
madman in a mask
[Music]
Riddler's back in Gotham Riddler he
hasn't been seen in years
well he's putting on quite a show
[Music]
there's a squad on the way don't be
there shortly be ready for a fight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please please we can make the deal
anything you want our issues can be
solved with handshakes Maury this is
what happens when you back out of a deal
with me there's only one way you're
getting out of this alive you have to
solve a riddle and I choose my words
count if I were you
listen closely no please don't do this
without fingers I point without arms I
strike without feet
I run Who am I
I've got visual that drone fully
functional I'll need a place to drop in
without being noticed
time for some recon
it's a tricky one isn't it a mine vendor
that scratches at the very nature of
power some kind of torture device
doesn't seem like he's getting out until
he guesses the riddle this Riddler
certainly has an imagination ruler a
terror from the past I never thought I'd
see him on our streets again he's not to
be taken lightly
remember choose your words carefully
Morrie
you only have so many thrillers taken
hostages casino patrons innocent
bystanders they're clearly not his main
target must be an insurance policy
cashiers booth that'll do just need to
take out the guard first
audio playback fully functional time
distraction
[Music]
I'm losing patience mari are you
expecting a hint give me an answer
Batman we kick it in the front covered
by gunmen and they've got the back
barricade in the blackjack tables how
should i deploy when we're inside I'm
relying on your eyes and ears what's the
best course of action we need a
distraction find a way to limit their
line of sight sounds like a plan you're
completely insane
no I don't believe that's it I'll clear
a path wait for my seat
give them hell we're counting on you
back there you're ahead of schedule I'm
a little busy right now but I'll see if
I can fit you in not him the hostage
shoot the hostage
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i Yvette's the batman clearly isn't
using this hat
break it open with pleasure
I've heard stories in the streets about
you Batman
you're the biggest name in Gotham since
well since I left town everyone's very
impressed with you I'm not impressed
Gotham's criminals have become zealots
and thugs in cheap suits and you I've
come home to find a wannabe in my chair
eating my goddamn porridge this is my
city
Gotham is forgotten you Riddler crawl
back under your rock before you get hurt
says the man with a hook at his throat
you're supposedly the world's greatest
detective yet here you are completely at
my mercy I don't see much evidence of
that I expected more of a battle for you
bound
you have to be kidding
clever but not smart enough
how it was that risk in a day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Rowley I can comment straight hurt it
just doesn't do it for me
[Music]
[Music]
follow the powerlines there must be a
weak point
[Music]